hello I'm a Whitman I'm Jay and levy and
today we will be discussing murderous
Ralph well you will like it though it's
very cool and stressful and cool you
like murder me too
it's 1924 Marine Dallas Watkins
she's just graduated from you and then
she was like you know what this I want
to tell the truth she moves to Chicago
this town of jazz ass drink drink
crime and she started working this is
Chicago Tribune and she was like yeah
I've got a job the Chicago Tribune and
I'm gonna investigate what I gotta
investigate and that's what she really
wanted to do oh yeah and then she comes
upon this editor it was a man the editor
was like marine I'm the maasai nude yeah
the cooks County Jail's murderous row
which is where they keep the women who
are awaiting trial and he was like
you're a woman nobody else wants to
report on this a little boring for
our male reporters I care about the
goods so give me the goods baby and she
was like I got you bitch
I guess you wasn't murderers row in Cook
County Jail she meets Sabella needy an
Italian immigrant who is accused of
murdering her husband she says he heard
I did kill him but because he hurt me
and Maureen is like this is it Maureen
went to her editor and was like I heard
about sub a honey a the-- and he was
like no bitch like i don't care about
Sabella needy the problem was he wanted
something juicy this editor
roaster he said to her look I need you
to bring me something juicy as hell
really like get excited about over like
you can say some sexy like you can
like yeah you don't know me
[Music]
and then all of a sudden Belva Gartner
is arrested she was a cabaret dancer she
was like yes my lover was found sprawled
out dead as hell across the front seat
of a car she was like look I'm just a
woman and I was basically possessed by
the devil which is jazz meanwhile
Maureen was like oh my god
yes yes yes exactly what I need to make
my career I love Goss I love Jews
my editors gonna eat this yeah so that
was her first big break
so then within like I don't even know
how many minutes
not many she gets this other lady bila
anon and Buell anons arrested she has
had a lover's spat
and they both we reach for a pistol and
from our beam Beulah was like and while
he was laying on the floor
she played who Lulu and she danced her
on his grave and she made multiple
cocktails and she drank them
Beulah says I was takin a hold of by
drinking alcohol and listening to jazz
music and like me I guess it was just
like a bunch of but marina is
like oh my god I'm getting the juice
that my editor asked me before hell yes
the newspaper comes out these women
realize right away we have got to look
good because that's what this is
about is looking good and they're like
if I cut my hair and I do my mascara
right and I go do my eyeliner right and
I move my hips right and I cry at the
right moment they're not going to
convict me so they start a beauty school
within murderous Roe do they call it
anything they called it murderous Roe
beauty school calm they were ahead of
their time
and they're like taking these women that
are like huh I just
and rip somebody's head off yesterday
and they're like I know but like sit
down sweetie
these roses are actually incredibly
intelligent because they know how to
work their angle and they're like so
it's 1924 and marine most murderous row
then she interviews the girls before
they go to trial they were like I'm
sorry but we love jazz and drink week we
love our jobs we'd love to do this thing
and they were like oh we would never
kill a man because a man would never
mean enough to a woman for her to just
murder
obviously and Maureen is like these
women are obviously guilty the evidence
is laid out on the table
these women are guilty she didn't care
about that so she's like writing these
stories that are like super tabloid
salacious anything these women had to
say got spun into this big juicy circus
okay so we're at the trial
after months of covering this story and
the girls have their like sideways caps
and their nice blue wide setup isin
scheming as if and their lawyer etc was
like my client is pregnant they weren't
pregnant but they were like I'm pregnant
my lawyer told me to say I was pregnant
and the reporters were like oh my god
look at these girls their haircuts and
their manicures like they could never
commit a crime and on top of that they
might be carrying a baby bee and
Marina's like typing on the computer
that's not an idea she's like sexy
ladies do the thing that you think that
they never could do I mean Maureen got
caught up let's not mince words
Marie him got him caught up in the
sexiness of the whole thing like her
agenda wasn't necessarily to
sensationalized but the stories were so
like
dramatic that she had to at the end of
the trials they were like look I was
very ill because someone named jazz mom
came to me and I feel concerned and I
feel that I was someone who explored the
realm too heavily and I need help and
like that woman was like I can't I head
cetera Altadena etc etc and the boys
you're right all right we don't care
when it you did it you're so much say
you wanna you we don't care which makes
sense
juries back then all-male and the men
were basically like okay let me just
tell you this you've spent four months
in the system four months is too long
they were like yeah you better go home
and raise some babies you cuties and
they were like yeah I'm there we're like
I will go and they basically these women
got off after four months after these
women murdered their lovers in cold
blood
Maureen after this happened she took a
step back and she said to herself I have
been a part of freeing these clearly
guilty women who used their feminine
wiles to get free that was my big fault
meanwhile Sybilla nithi got hanged and
it was the first time that Maureen was
like I'm sorry I did the wrong thing
this is stuff I've this situation up so
Maureen women's groups and sibel Anita's
lawyers came together to change the laws
and they made it possible for women to
be on juries
and then Maureen was like I gotta talk
about this like thing that happened to
me and she wrote a play called yeah okay
I can't wait to release my hiccup we can
let him out my ever nice so she wrote a
play that was called two brave Little
Women which it's hard to understand
because it sounds like Little Women but
it's not so years and years and years
after she died Bob Fosse got the rights
for her play and then made it into
Chicago which turned into the
longest-running musical on Broadway of
all time what is the moral of this story
that's a very good question
women can be villains just as much as
they can be heroes went to win Best
Picture
shut up every shape
you